should we uh which what you want to do
you want it you want to get your little
you little doggy you want to get your
dog might as well let's yeah we might as
well
let's go buzzing I hit public though I
am public though why this is this is
somewhat of this is some dominatrix [ __ ]
like fetish [ __ ] which is fine but it's
done
not on Tik Tok yo on Twitter fine
Twitter's got more little sub
communities more little niches that if
you seek this stuff out then that's fine
no what are you talking about tick tock
got mad furry [ __ ] on there that's it I
mean dude yeah not on free time free
tick tock apparently look I'm not gonna
say I'm not gonna say that I'm not gonna
say that this is wrong but I am gonna
say don't be a dog
uh where is it annoying to be a dog
what do you mean like you know this this
this animal thing that she's doing
becoming a pet or whatever yeah at the
grocery store um you know what man I'm a
hot take I'm gonna say grocery stores
alright people bring their dogs and
groceries to her I'm gonna say that's
fine okay yeah that's fine at a oh when
you're trying to play spike ball okay
okay and there's a dog running around
and yeah you're gonna wording her step
on it yeah volleyball this is uh this is
such a good way this is such a good
excuse to cheat she's just in some other
dude is acting like a dog in their house
like babe what are you doing
no I'm in dog mode oh oh we were just
sniffing each other's asses Oh God I was
just sniffing his butthole that's all it
was what the tree you're cheating on me
geez dog mode activated
play this chat let's see it okay give me
the book hey hey give me the ball
I'm cringing so hard I just I would hate
to be this boyfriend cuz you got to
pretend like you can't get the ball from
her you get to flee get the ball from
her yeah yeah that's true
someone on all four is made yeah
just full mount just get the back roll
roll onto your back now it's you know
she's doing baseball bat grip you Yankee
ball right every month like I think
that's the part that sucks about it is
you got to pretend that you know yeah
it's hard for the for the other person
yeah yeah that's a good point
it's hard to get into it like for her
she's playing the role of a dog right
she's not even being human so it's
easier for you to get in that headspace
mm-hmm cuz it's more extreme whereas the
other guy has to pretend that it's just
him yeah seeing another human as a dog
yeah it's harder yeah this is the
toughest improv class I've ever seen
exactly yeah
I would dude we should make a movie and
we should cast that what's the [ __ ]
phrase for there's like a phrase I hold
up let me get this right Heather a cane
or some [ __ ]
that I would know this from reading
another relationship advice where a
dude's had to leave his girlfriend
because she assumed the persona of a cat
and it destroyed the relationship that
what what's away you gotta find that one
what's up now you have to find that one
because it's so relevant to this way
what's up what I just explained what's
right it again what's up um the thing is
dude when we talk about our EDD IT stuff
it's like you know
it's like we go into a trance and we
don't actually remember what we said
yeah okay someone did a right okay we'll
pull this up after so yes it's called
like nether something kin I don't know
what the [ __ ]
proper name but are there anywhere you
like assumed the persona of a sloth I
mean bro or like a snail yeah I mean I I
would have I would assume a snail yeah
yes I mean if I had to guess I would say
yeah dude a snail you just put a bike
helmet on each ass cheek and you cover
your stomach in grease and you're just
cool you go I know that's a worm yeah
but a worm it's slowly crawling in the
house just leaving sludge behind yeah
yeah seeping sludge I'm so please excuse
my snail she has dire itis my diet is
makes it really easy to get into my
snail headspace all I do was put my
bicycle helmets on my ass and I'm in my
snail head space all right babe
tonight I'm gonna be a grizzly I'm gonna
be a grizzly bear and you're just
standing on all fours on the countertop
eating bananas like a psycho what the
[ __ ] was I trying to say with this [ __ ]
dude anyway yeah oh we should cast a
movie or it's all boyfriends who have
girlfriends or vice versa that are you
know animal headspace people you know
cuz I bet you got great actors yeah
that's yeah Wow that's a good point
because they have they have to really
get into it and you could put them in
really crazy [ __ ] all right man
you're all Mars and you're fighting
aliens and the [ __ ] is about to blow up
action and they're just they're like
this is [ __ ] easy dude I've been you
won't you wouldn't believe this [ __ ] up
in a big deal of the best scenes that
I've done over the past now
this guy's a natural we got to make the
the nether King boyfriend movie anyway
let's watch the clip because we've done
everything oh no no no we did I meant I
wanted to watch the grocery store one
but I don't have it
search all it was in one of it was in a
thread somewhere through the top one of
the few comments from this thread killed
me the top one being I hate how much I
like this and then uh so disgusting
that's why I like it I can't find it god
dammit there was like one more
hmm it doesn't say your tik-tok name on
there on the actual video shouldn't it
be like oh yeah yeah yeah what is it
your puppy girl Jenna alright oh there
you go
whose puppy girl Jenna your puppy girl
Jenna your your puppy girl yeah ok it's
called this was the first one they
[ __ ] did oh boy I'm sending it to the
hole and I'm browsing thread
yeah the first one there it is man this
this feels like a like a ploy I find
something for tik toks from now here's
my only fans
I pray yeah I promise you yeah
[Music]
[Music]
get my water I'm still thirsty
it's like this stupid [ __ ] that dog
parents do on Instagram they give their
dog a voice yeah it's like that but she
has a voice she could just use it woman
who kills me about this frame is no one
there gives a [ __ ] that she's doing this
these three guys are wearing [ __ ]
Philly cheesesteaks and they're like huh
yeah yeah they're getting off on them
doing this in public like just the two
of them yeah meanwhile like no one gives
a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I do oh that's
weird
all right I gotta piss then let's jump
into the bonus oh [ __ ] okay damn it well
alright guys
you